with a total gross approaching 750
million dollars Suicide Squad proved to
be one of the DCE used most successful
films no matter how few stars critics
gave the first one we know a second ones
coming here's all the rumors and
spoilers leaked so far about the sequel
James Gunn was infamously temporarily
booted from the director's chair of the
upcoming guardians of the galaxy vol 3
over controversy regarding years old
tweets Marvel's initial loss proved to
be Warner Brothers game in October 2018
news dropped that gun was tapped to
write the sequel to Suicide Squad in
January 2019 The Hollywood Reporter
broke the news that the Marvel Studios
exile was negotiating to direct the
villainous squad's next adventure to gun
is planning a completely new take on
Task Force X and it may not be a direct
sequel in the strictest sense according
to Joe Blow Aquaman and Shazam producer
Peter Safran spilled a few details first
of all we don't call it Suicide Squad -
because it's a total reboot it's
everything you would hope from a James
Gunn script Gunn's film will be titled
The Suicide Squad and will relaunch the
franchise with a mostly all-new cast of
characters and actors Gunn has a large
toy box of characters from which to
choose the Suicide Squad comic has
featured dozens of different DC super
villains and there are plenty of squad
regular still waiting to appear on the
big screen
thr said The Suicide Squad we'll be
rooted in guns vibe which most likely
means we can expect the same unique
blend of action humor and drama the
director brought to his - guardians of
the galaxy films at the beginning at the
script stage I created all in my head
and then it's simply a matter of trying
to make the movie look like what's in my
head no other guardians of the galaxy
star vocally disagreed with Disney's
decision to fire gun as much as Dave
Bautista he threatened to break his
contract for guardians of the galaxy vol
3 if Disney didn't use gun script it's
no surprise that almost as soon as it
was announced that gun would be working
on the Suicide Squad Bautista was
congratulating him on Twitter but ceased
his tweet inspired a quick response with
fans speculating who the former WWE star
should play one of the
our common nominations was bane the
ruthless strongman who famously broke
Batman's back and was first portrayed in
live-action by Tom Hardy and Christopher
Nolan's The Dark Knight Rises
while the bane of the comics was only
briefly a member of Suicide Squad he was
a regular in the comic book secret 6
which also featured supervillains as
protagonists according to Collider
peacemaker a violent pacifist who
believes in peace so much he's willing
to kill to achieve it is the role gun
once for the guardians of the galaxy
star when peacemaker first appeared on
the comic book stands it was part of the
now-defunct Charlton comics whose
superhero properties were acquired by DC
Comics he's also one of the Charlton
refugees writer Alan Moore wanted to use
for Watchmen when DC editor dick
Giordano told Moore that DC wanted to
save the Charlton characters for other
things
Moore replaced the Charlton superheroes
with his own altered versions of them
peacemakers replacement was the comedian
whose murder sets off the events of
Watchmen in January 2019 The Hollywood
Reporter confirmed a scheduled release
month for the relaunch August 2021
since suicide squads 2016 release there
have been plenty of questions about
whether there would even be a sequel
writing duties have changed hands
several times and it was never clear
whether director David Ayer would return
to the director's chair as early as
February 2017 rumors were circulating
that Mel Gibson was being courted to
helm the sequel while gun is confirmed
as writer and possibly director of the
follow-up film it shouldn't be too
surprising that there will ultimately be
five years between the first and second
movies it may be that the extra time
will work in the suicide squads favor
with gun reportedly pursuing a new
direction with a largely new cast the
added time may allow memories of the
first movie to fade and pave the way for
a fresh start in February 2019 for
boarded the in spite of the character's
unquestionable popularity Margot Robbie
won't be reprising her role as Harley
Quinn in the Suicide Squad in its piece
about the state of the DC EU Forbes
wrote that Quinn was being jettisoned
from the Suicide Squad franchise as
of guns rethinking of the property and
the new flavor he wanted to bring to it
Robbie's days as Harley Quinn aren't
over though as she will be appearing in
the upcoming birds of prey and the
fantabulous Emancipation of one harley
quinn bad guys it's what we do but that
wasn't the end of the story the week
after publishing the story online Forbes
contributor Mark Hughes posted a
correction saying he had been wrong
about no home for Harley in the follow
up Hughes wrote I've learned from
sources close to production that in fact
Robbie as Harley Quinn is indeed
expected to appear in James Gunn's The
Suicide Squad which is expected to begin
production later this year in late
February 20 1940 that Will Smith opted
not to reprise his role as Floyd Lawton
aka Deadshot the Sharpshooter assassin
Smith played in the first Suicide Squad
Variety says there's no bad blood
between Smith and Warner Brothers
instead it looks like scheduling is to
blame pleasure doing business with you
Warner Brothers was hoping Smith would
be one of the actors to return if
Deadshot is missing in action in the new
film it will be somewhat fitting in the
comics he's proven to be one of the most
consistent presences in the various task
force ex rosters if they're much more
fluid than other comics super teams a
Suicide Squad movie with no dead shot
might be regrettable but the character
is an eccentric 'el as Chris Evans
Captain America would be to an Avengers
movie screen rant has proposed a
promising fix plucking Joe Manganiello
Deathstroke out of the DC EU limbo to
replace Smith or maybe Smith will be
replaced with a new Deadshot thr
reported that MCU veteran interest elbow
was in talks to replace Smith in the
park according to the story Elba met
with James Gunn and early March 2019 and
the discussion went so swimmingly that
elbow was ready to dive right into
negotiations it's an interesting
development particularly considering
some of the less than glowing comments
that surfaced from elbow while playing
Asgardian gate keeper Heimdall in the
Marvel Studios films Elba played
Heimdall for all three Thor films
Avengers age of Ultron and finally
Avengers infinity war
when his character met his end at the
gauntlet wearing hand of Thanos Elba
raised a few eyebrows when he expressed
frustration with working on Marvel
movies in a 2014 interview with The
Telegraph if Alba's willing to jump back
into the world of superheroes so soon
after that oh s--- liberated him from
the role of Heimdall then the chat with
Gunn must have really gone swimmingly in
the same story that announced a dress
elbow was gunning for the role of
Deadshot thr also cited sources telling
them Joel Kinnaman would not be
reprising his role as Task Force X
watchdog ricflack the story said that
while most of the cast of 2016 Suicide
Squad would be set aside for newer blood
there were three characters in
particular that were expected to return
Deadshot Harley Quinn and Flagg but
sources conflict some say Kinnaman is
expected to return and others expect the
character will be cut from the team the
shooting starts and it will you'll cut
and run what would be interesting is if
Rick Flagg does appear in the sequel and
Kinnaman steps down from the role
forcing filmmakers to recast the part
with Deadshot recast and potentially
Flagg eventually we might just be able
to call the sequel Suicide Squad the
recasting the question of just how soft
to reboot James Gunn's Suicide Squad
will be seems to get more complicated
with every related news story and it
grew a little more complex with the news
of at least one alumnus of 2016 Suicide
Squad returning the Task Force X talking
to Business Insider in March 2019 Jai
Courtney confirmed he would reprised the
role of Captain Boomerang in the
upcoming film Courtney said he wasn't
free to reveal too many details but
added that the Suicide Squad would be
shooting in a few months time and that
he was glad to be back in the fold
he said I'm happy it's going to be fun
it will be different for sure but it's
going to be great the news is something
of a surprise as the rumblings until now
have suggested that while the studio was
hoping for the returns of Will Smith
Margot Robbie and Viola Davis to their
roles the rest of the cast would likely
be replaced Collider has reportedly
gotten word of who some of Task Force
X's other members would be one shouldn't
come as much of a surprise
fans of The Suicide Squad comic King
shark the savage man shark hybrid was
one of the characters predicted and the
choice makes sense
when DC rebooted its entire superhero
comic book universe in 2011 with the new
52 king shark became one of the squad's
first members likewise he accompanied
the squad and Batman in the 2014
animated film Batman assault on Arkham
the character also appeared prominently
in CW's the flash in the episode King
shark versus Gorilla Grodd if colliders
report is true some of the other
characters proved gun isn't exactly
pulling from DC's a list of bad guys the
site says suicide squads roster will
include two Batman villains who fall
squarely in the D list a female version
of the ratcatcher
a former exterminator who commits crimes
with an army of rats she controls and
the Polka Dot man who can turn the polka
dots on his costume into gadgets the
beginning of 2019 was a good time for
writer director James Gunn in mid March
deadline broke possibly the best news of
the year thus far Disney had rehired him
as the director for guardians of the
galaxy vol 3
while most MCU fans were likely over the
moon adhering the news fans of DC Comics
adaptations might have been a little
concerned
after all if Gunn was back on guardians
did that mean he dropped the Suicide
Squad like a bad habit and run back home
according to Aquaman and Shazam producer
Peter Safran the answer to that is a
definitive no speaking to Joe Blow
Safran said it was all handled
incredibly elegantly and everybody knows
on both sides that Suicide Squad is the
priority today guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 Safran said we'll be guns next
film after the Suicide Squad that means
according to Screen Rant
Guardians fans will have to wait until
2023 at the earliest for the next entry
in the series this is no
spectres congressman what do you expect
us to do while we wait
according to production weekly the
Suicide Squad will be under the working
title El Dorado once it enters
production there's no indication exactly
why El Dorado was chosen or if it's at
all relevant to the film's story the
name is usually associated with a
legendary city in South America whose
very structures and roads were said to
be made of solid gold the city has been
the subject of numerous films and it's a
popular subject in music as well
everyone from the 80s punk band Agent
Orange to metal gods Iron Maiden and alt
rockers Death Cab for Cutie have
recorded in Eldorado saw Shakira named
her 2017 album El Dorado of course as a
working title El Dorado doesn't
necessarily need to have any connection
whatsoever with the film story though
it'd be pretty great if it means gun
plans to make the Suicide Squad an
animated musical check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the DC EU are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]